Daniel Friedman: Hello and welcome.
This is ActInf GuestStream 47.1 on July
10, 2023.
We're here with Nick Byrd and Samuel
Bellini-Leite, and we're going to have a
presentation followed by a discussion.
So thank you both for joining.
And Sam, thanks again for this
presentation.
Off to you.
Samuel Bellini-Leite: Okay?
Was Nick going to say something before I
started?
I can go ahead.
Okay, so some introduction first.
I'm a professor at Minas Gerais State
University.
I'm a psychologist philosopher, mainly
working in cognitive science.
I'm going to talk about what I did in my
PhD thesis and also some renewed interest
I had on this based on some developments
in large language models which happened
this year, most notably Chain of Thoughts
and Tree of Thoughts.
Those additions to large language model
made me want to come back to this again
and talk about this.
So how do we know about human reasoning,
which is the subject, the main subject
underlying this topic?
Well, we had empirical research from the
60s, starting with Peter Watson, who was
challenging the notion that we have a
logic module for reasoning or some
general understanding of logic when we're
adults.
And he crafted tasks which were hard to
solve, but they had actually simple
fundamentals to it, which were taken to
show people's irrationality, something
like that.
And also a huge tradition that's called
Heuristics and Biases that also started
in the mainly by Kanmen and Amosverskin,
which had similar tasks and went beyond,
and they even won the Nobel Prize for
this work.
I had here on the slides Evolutionary
Psychology and Language and Pragmatics,
which were also people in the 90s working
with this sort of research.
But I'm going to talk about dual process
theory in the way they formulated by
Evans and Stanovich, which mainly
summarizes the results of Watson and
common risk biases literature.
So I'm going to talk about how dual
process theory came to be and then some
problems that it has that I tried to
address.
So one of the first reasoning tests in
this trend literature was the Watson
selection test, which goes like this
please indicate which cards can determine
if the following rule is false.
If a card has a vowel on one side, then
has an even number on the other side.
This sounds like a simple exercise.
So the card A clearly is relevant because
it has a vowel on one side.
If it doesn't have an even number on the
other, then the statement is false.
And everyone can find this neatly of most
people.
But the problem comes with the card seven,
, which is not so intuitive.
People actually choose the second card
two there, which has an even number on
one side.
But having that even number doesn't help
at all to determine if the statement is
false.
What does help is which is an odd number,
if it has a file the other side, then the
statement could be.
So this was one of the tasks that famous
for and conman and first key show them
this one they're famous task as well
solved the conjunction fallacy the issue
that people arise when solving this task
goes like this it is a 31 years old,
single, outspoken and very bright.
She majored in philosophy as a student.
She was deeply concerned with issues of
discrimination and social justice and
also participated in anti nuclear
demonstrations.
Please make the following statements by
their probability using one for the most
probable and eight for the least probable.
.
What's interesting here is the statement,
the last statement.
Linda is a bank teller and isn't active
active in the feminist movement.
Because there's also these statements
without one another, without the
conjecture which is Linda is active in
the feminist movement and Linda is a bank
teller.
Because of the description, people think
that Linda is a feminist is very likely
given the description, but they think
being a bank teller is not likely.
The issue is that people usually mark
Linda is a bank teller and is a feminist
as more likely than being a bank teller.
The problem here is that the conjunction
of the two necessarily is less likely.
So being a feminist plus being something
else or being a bank teller plus being
something else is automatically less
likely.
So those are the sort of tasks that the
reasoning literature used to show some
sort of human irrationality.
One issue with this is that it's not very
interesting to show that humans are
irrational, it's more interesting to show
how humans reason.
And also these sort of studies didn't
show how people actually solved the
problems.
They were actually focused on how people
made mistakes.
One thing that's interesting about dual
process theory is that it explains both
the mistakes and the solutions to the
answers.
So in 2002, Conan and Frederick
formulated this cognitive reflection test
which is another one of these tasks but a
lot much simpler and elegant.
And it really shows indicates at least
how dual process theory is a good
solution to a good explanation of the
evidence in general.
So yeah, the western selection test used
logic and the Linda task used probability.
.
And here we just have basic arithmetic.
So as if math we don't have to worry
about which answer is truly correct or
which rational norms we need to follow.
It's just basic math.
There's nothing to discuss here.
Right?
So the task goes like this a bat and ball
costs one in ten in total.
You might know this test, it's a famous
test even out of the reasoning literature,
, the bat costs one more than ball.
How much does the ball cost?
So people when when people read this,
they usually say $0.10 intuitively.
But if you take a little time to write
write it down, you can see that it's
actually $0.05.
So the bat cost one and ball costs $0.05.
.
Together it costs one and ten.
The other two have a similar structure.
The point here is that sometimes we look
at these tests and we have an intuitive
answer which is wrong.
And the way we get out of these issues is
that we stop and think a little bit and
review our answers with some sort of step
by step reasoning or writing it down,
something like that.
What's interesting here is if you look at
two plus two, it's almost impossible not
to think four.
It's almost like you're perceiving.
The answer is four just by looking at it.
.
But if you have some sort of more complex
calculation to do, obviously just by
looking at it, you won't have a solution.
.
So this basic intuition is clearly shown
in the cognitive reflection test.
And what's more interesting about it is
that the cognitive reflection test
actually predicts the performance of
various Aristocrats and Biases tests.
So if someone does well on cognitive
reflection test, they're more likely to
go well on any other reasoning task.
And if they go bad on the cognitive
reflection test, they likely will go bad
on other reasoning tests as well.
To me, this is also an indication that
this dual process structure of intuitive
reasoning versus slow reasoning,
reflective reasoning, likely explains the
rest of the text as well.
Not only these two, but most of the
others.
So it's a good explanation of the
literature.
Okay, so what does the theory say besides
besides explaining the reasoning
literature?
So, in 2008, Jonathan Evans tried to make
a formulation of it that would include
and unify views from different domains
such as social cognition, neurosciences,
other people in psychologists which had
similar theories.
And it seems like there's something in
common here to unify, but Evans wasn't
able to.
And so there's a formulation specific for
reasoning and we don't know if it applies
so much well to other areas of cognition.
.
One common way to describe dual process
theory is by making these tables of
features.
So we say, oh, type one processes have
these sorts of features on the left, and
type two processes have this other type
of features on the right.
This table here was one I made by joining
some of the features of Evans
insteadovich, and also of Kunman, and
then with some questions I raised in the
thesis, I elaborated it this way, but it'
's very similar to the Yavin Instant
formulation.
One problem we have with this tables
formulation of the Duo Process Theory is
that usually people agree that in one
thinking instance, when you're solving a
problem, you're not going to have all of
those features together.
So we don't know for sure when some
feature will be present or not, for
instance.
So clear that type one processes
necessarily have to be unconscious and
type two processes necessarily have to be
conscious.
I think that comes a lot because of some
conceptual issues in the theory.
But one solution they have found was to
have at least some defining features but
different authors have different defining
features.
So here I have some of the defining
features of the main authors, which is
type one processes use less working
memory while type two processes most
strongly on working memory.
Type one processes aren't autonomous in
the sense that they don't need to wait
for higher processing to respond.
If they have an answer, they go for it.
And using the couple's representations
mean that means that type two systems can
reason beyond what's in the present
environment can think about things that
are not there.
Type one processing is faster in
comparison while two is slower in
comparison.
Type one processing is less effortful
while two is more effortful in the sense
of psychological effort.
Like people report having a hard time
doing things.
So for instance in the cognitive
reflection test, people that solve the
test correctly usually rate it and it's
harder because they had to use tattoo
processing to solve it.
Okay, but Samuels, which is a philosopher,
, dual process theory and other subjects,
he says okay, even if these features
proposal is good, we still need a
mechanism to explain why these features
are linked together.
So what is the mechanism that explains
why type one processing features go
together and what is the mechanism that
explains why type two processing goes
together?
So we need some beyond saying that they'
're different, we need to explain what
are these mechanisms that make them
different?
And I actually had Samuels on my PhD
committee and I'm not sure if he was
convinced with my solution.
So my PhD was a solution to this problem.
.
I'm not sure how he was convinced of it,
but he approved the PhD, so that's good
enough, I guess.
Yeah.
So the goal was to solve the unity
problem, was to explain the mechanisms
that explain type one processing and
explain the mechanisms that explain type
two processing.
And I started to see, to search in the
literature first, how people were
conceiving of the general frameworks that
were behind these two types of reasoning
and one that was not actually related to
this literature of dual process theory
but was actually famous in cognitive
science, was the modularity of mind in
the 80s proposed by philosopher Jared
Schroder.
And he said that we had two types of
processes, a modular process mostly
related to input and perception and we
had central processes that was mostly
related to higher reasoning.
So you can trace some sort of resemblance
there to do process theory.
And the way he went about this is that he
said these perceptual models, modular
processes are information encapsulated.
So vision only works with vision and
language only works with language, space
only works with space.
And so these were domain specific
knowledge systems that did not
communicate with each other and when they
needed contact sensitivity, they needed
central processes.
So these central processes he would argue,
, were Isotropic and Quinine, which means
that any type of information could be
used in a solution so we can relate, I
don't know, physics with biology and form
a new solution.
So there's knowledge from multiple
domains working here that would also need
some sort of context sensitivity, which
was a problem for photo.
He didn't think we would solve this
context sensitivity problem at all and he
had good reasons for that.
In classic AI.
We had a lot of issues with that.
I mean, we still do have issues with the
context sensitivity problem, but not the
sort of issues we had in the 80s when
they were debating this same problem of
classical AI.
So this problem was a problem of how to
represent a changing environment in
symbolic representation.
So yeah, it was a problem because
classical AI attempted to give knowledge
to robots or artificial intelligence and
statements about the world and they were
intractable, hard to compute, there are
so many knowledge banks to search and so
many knowledge to try to use that the
robots couldn't do anything relevant.
They also couldn't represent change.
So the changing environment was terrible
for them, didn't work with this symbolic
representation, it didn't work with
serial reasoning or anything like of the
sort.
This was a huge problem for classic
cognitive scientists.
And since photo was a believer in
cognitive science in the sense of a
classical computational theory of mind or
language of thought theory, he said that
he had found Photo's first law of the
nonexistence of cognitive science.
This law states that the more processes
are global, the less cognitive science
will be able to understand them.
So he thought only these encapsulated
processes could be studied.
And if we needed this sort of global and
context sensitive type of processing,
then contest science just couldn't do it
because he had in mind contra science in
the sense of classical AI.
But it also seems not only folder, it
seems that the literature abandoned
classical cognitive science in various
ways, which were strange because if you
take the work of Alan Newell and Herbert
Simon, it's strange to think that oh,
they were completely wrong.
There's nothing, nothing useful that they
say that could be applied today.
All the evidence, all the theories they
made are just completely wrong.
That's a weird way of thinking.
And well, if you take for instance, our
theories today of the human Bayesian
brain, they don't consider this at all.
It's just like they don't care.
It's a different strand of theories.
But it also seemed to me that there must
be at least something wrong about,
something right about this shouldn't be
totally abandoned.
There must be a place for these results.
Explanation of the Mind one thing that
was in odds with the way Photer described
his dual process theory, and also
sometimes Stan of a trend talks about
dual process theory.
It seems like forgetting this fact here
is the fact that we have a limited
capacity when we use conscious processing
or working memory.
And this is one of the best evidence in
psychology we have so far.
We had behaviorist evidence for
reinforcement, enforcement, learning and
that stuff and then we had cognitive
psychology in the this is the best
evidence that cognitive psychology has
had for a long time.
So it's also something we should not
simply ignore.
So we have in short term memory the
knowledge that when we store some
information in short term memory, we
usually can only keep track of about
seven items, sometimes even less in
selective attention.
There was this task where there was a
video of people playing basketball and
the subjects had to count how many passes
they were making and suddenly a gorilla
passed by on the scene and people didn't
notice the gorilla because they were so
concentrated on the task, which is some
evidence of selective attention.
That is, when you're concentrating on
tasks, you actually don't even see other
stimuli.
We have also a competition for limited
resources when doing dual tasks, or if I'
'm talking on the phone and writing at
the same time, I'm probably not going to
do a very good writing because we're
competing for limited resources.
And it's important to note that if you're
walking and writing or walking and
talking, since those are different tasks,
they won't compete.
So we have some competition.
We have more competition when these
limited resources are disputed also in
working memory.
So if I say the number 793241 and I ask
you to repeat them backwards and you're
not looking at the slides, you're going
to have a hard time with that.
Because of the limited capacity of
working memory, when it's clear that in
other areas of our thinking of our brain
is using a lot more information than
seven items to make the scenes happen,
perception and to make us walk and so on.
.
So that's on the side of the type two
constraints, on the side of type one
reasoning.
Our Audi has some intuitions similar to
the ones I described.
So he said from its earlier days.
The research that RSD and I conducted was
guided by the idea that intuitive
judgments acquired position between the
automatic operations of perception and
the deliberate operations of reasoning.
Communric claimed that intuitive thinking
is perception like and that intuitive
predictions is an operation of system one
further that the boundary between
perception and judgment is fuzzy and
permeable.
The perception of a stranger as menacing
is inseparable from a prediction of
future harm.
So you can see that this is very likely,
very similar, sorry, to the intuitions
that we were speaking on when we're
talking about predictive processing.
So feminine saying when you look at a
face of someone and he's mad, you have a
prediction that you're in trouble,
right?
So this is a sort of judgment, that same
sort of perception, and also the context
sensitivity is pretty much solved in
predictive processing.
And if you take on the AI literature that
also happens.
For instance, paper attention is all you
need.
They have some tips for how to deal with
context sensitivity, which photo didn't
dream of.
So this is something that Clark said in
2013.
The best overall fit between driving
signal and expectations will often be
found by, in effect, inferring noise, in
the driving signal and thus recognizing a
stimulus as, for example, the letter M
say in the context of the word.
Mother, even though the same bare
stimulus presented out of context or in
most other contexts, would have been a
better fit with the letter N.
A unit normally responsive to the letter
M might, under such circumstances, be
successfully driven by an N like stimulus.
.
So what is Clark is trying to say here
that since we represent using probability,
, then if the context says we should go
left, we go left.
If the context says we should go right,
we go right, because the representation
is fluid and it accepts changes really
quickly.
So that's something that stems from the
predictive processing architecture.
But one issue I think that we might see
in the predictive processing architecture
is the lack of compositionality.
So symbolic representations exhibit
compositionalities meaning that complex
representations are built by combining
simpler elements according to rules or
syntax.
The meaning of a complex representation
is derived from the meanings of its
constituent parts in the way they are
combined.
This property allows for the generation
of new and meaningful expressions by
manipulating symbolic structures.
So Folder in 88 argues that even if
connectionist models succeed, they would
likely have some sort of simulation of a
language of thoughts that exhibits
conventionality in order to work like we
do.
And we'll see that it seemed like it's
the case with the results we have this
year.
So considering those constraints and the
initial field footer and the problem I
was trying to solve, which is the unity
problem for blue process theory, a major
shift I had on the PhD thesis.
And then I wrote a chapter on this book.
The Chan Book of Founded Rationality with
Keith.
So we explain here in this book the
chapter The Shift Power Structure, which
is, I mean, it's not clear that a dual
process theory theorists would adopt
Folder, but it's still very similar.
The way the received view of dual process
theory works, which is type one, is a
number of dumb heuristics blind modules
and animal intelligence.
And then type two is the real contextual
and complex reasoning, the real human
intelligence.
So I tried to invert that power structure
by saying that the contextual, predictive
processing is a type one reasoning, which
is giving us the basics to reason on.
So our reasoning already comes with
context.
We don't need to reason the context with
type two reasoning.
We only use type two reasoning to fix
some minor issues in predictive
processing.
And we use heuristic search because it's
limited.
We only use it when there's a lot of
prediction error and predictions aren't
working that well.
And then we call for this heuristic
search to handle whatever is missing to
see if we can find a new solution that
wasn't captured.
So in this case the powerful system is
the predictive processing and not the
Type Two research.
So that was the general idea for this
shift.
Now I'm going to say some hypotheses that
stem from this shift.
So t one processes deal with content
encoded in the form of probability
density functions, which is how
predictive processing uses to represent
the world, which means there is no symbol
and no definite content but values, means,
, standard deviation.
Influenced by previous movements in
previous world contingencies,
manipulating prior information, biases
the distribution to one or another
direction closer to or further from a
certain value.
So people here in the active entrance
institute we know this by heart.
I'm not changing anything here, I'm just
using what they say.
Basically these functions are not stored
in a memory bank but distributed from the
responsible brain regions over to the
external organs, body parts through
neural connections.
The values in the distribution do not
represent objects directly indiscreetly
they refer to distinct aspects of the
input when perceptual systems are dealing
with such objects this is aligned with
the T one processes being easily biased
when working with references to similar
properties like similar numbers, objects,
rhymes or pet names very often an
incorrect value is picked from a
distribution.
An example that I have from this is when
usually I have seen people confuse their
youngest child with their dog name
youngest child and when someone has
another new child then the new youngest
child is often confused with the dog
because they are, I think, somewhat
represented in similar distribution
similar points of the distribution.
This is also in line with claimants of
embodied proposals that the world is not
representative in symbols.
T one processes are subpersonal and their
predictions are made by the same systems
which process perception.
A clear example is that a judgment about
a facial expression is related to the FFA
which is a region brain that processes
faces and this is also related to that
judgment that conman may argue that when
looking at someone we make judgments
about their face.
The idea is that perception is not
passive but already comes with
predictions and when in problem solving
such prediction is precisely the Type One
answer.
So if we look back at the reasoning test
all those Type One tests are likely
stemming from predictions.
I don't know what to claim that T one
processes are purely perceptual if in
contest to cognitive only that such
predictions reasoning is that there's not
a clear line between what is perception
and cognitive.
So I think the word you're just using
different words for this is the problem.
So just not getting into that convenience.
.
Example of judgment of negative spatial
expression shows how this is expected of
dual process theory like it's expected of
dual process theory that Type One reason
works under predictive processing, also
in line with the claims of embody
cognition that there is no sharp link
between perception and reasoning.
On the other hand, c two processing works
like a classical machine for reasoning,
such as General Problem Solver of Newman
Simon.
However, this classical machine only
makes sense in the brain if it exists in
a wider setup.
Predictive processing network generating
Type One responses like in Newell's
Physical Symbol system, when facing a
reasoning problem, T Two Processing opens
a problem space containing an expression
that designates the initial problem and
an expression designates a solution which
was produced by a probabilistic
prediction having the initial expression
and the predictive expression in the
problem space.
T Two Processing then uses its move
generators to attempt to reduce
differences between them and sometimes
find different solutions in such bad.
So let me just explain this a little bit
better.
When Newell was working in the 60s there
they knew they couldn't search all
possible space of a problem space because
it wouldn't work.
So they have this library search which
works like a detective, let's ignore the
problems which are likely wrong, just
look at the spaces that might be right.
What this predicting and reflecting
framework does for a risk search is that
the risk of search only works on boards
already with the prediction that was sent
from Type One processing.
So it's like we only start reasoning and
making searches based on the prior
predictions we already had.
And we only go further with this search
when the predictions aren't working.
And the main point here is that the risk
search isn't searching a random space or
even a pre programmed space.
It's searching a space that was left out
from the predictions that started in Type
One processing.
So that's how it doesn't go to the frame
problem anymore because a large part of
the contextual issue was also already
solved by predictive processes.
Okay, so that was the general hypothesis
I presented to attempt to solve the unity
problem, which is the problem of how Type
One features go together and how Type Two
features go together.
And now I'm going to try to argue that
this is likely the case, since that I can'
't prove this is the case.
But there are good reasons for us to
think that Type One processes use
predictive processing and that Type Two
processes do not use predictive
processing.
Rather they need some kind of symbolic
heuristic search.
One thing that stems out of is a good
explanation for the difference between
implicit representation and explicit
representation.
If you look at the literature in
psychology, you will see that it's very
ambiguous in these definitions.
Like people use implicit and explicit
representations as the same thing as
unconscious, conscious or fleeting
graspable, or the same thing as automatic
in control.
And so when it goes to dual process
theory, it's not very clear what they're
saying in each case, but they use this
expression and explicit a lot.
How I think this model solves this is by
saying that implicit representations are
probability density functions while
explicit representations are symbolic
representations.
Classical symbolic symbolic
representation.
Clark in his book sometimes mentions that
we can have single peak distribution
distributions.
But the problem with having single peak
distributions is that well, if you only
have one peak on the distribution
function then it doesn't have all these
features of probabilistic representation.
.
It's more likely similar to a symbolic
representation.
The fact that having a single peak
distribution might be the way that a
probability representation turns to a
symbolic representation.
So these have different and important
features.
The probability representation is
continuous, it's uncertain and ambiguous
and that's why it's able to be sensitive
to context.
The mother example of part it can vary on
retrieval.
We can remember something and be
different the second time.
It's tied to priors.
It works with statistical relations.
Yeah, it's called in and depending on
which value it's most probable at the
time, it has a different outcome.
So I argue that explicit representations
are likely discrete, they are likely
symbolic in nature, they're unambiguous.
This is what allows us to disabilite in
the first place they're stored reliably.
If you have a reliable definition of it,
you will likely remember it the same way
the next time.
It's arbitrary in the sense that it's not
really coupled to the stimuli, in the
sense that the perception of perception
usually is.
The statistical relations are related to
aspects of the world.
It's using compositionality and it's
immutable in the sense that you can't
change it.
It's fixed value doesn't change.
So that's the implicit versus explicit
feature.
You can have also explanations for
automaticity in contrast to working
memory.
So automaticity concerns overlearn skills
and overlearn skills are understood as
skills that have become predictable in
this framework.
So we usually use this to explain like
driving, riding a bicycle, riding.
So when you're driving, if you don't know
how to drive, you need certain statements,
, like some statements about how you, how
you should steer, right?
You need to have those in mind.
But then once you learn how to drive, it'
's like your body already knows what it's
doing and you don't even need to think
about this.
So this is the classical distinction in
psychology.
But I argue that the predictive
processing theory makes a new
enlightenment to this.
So it's like our body is predicting what
we're doing.
So it's automatic.
So it's an explanation for optimisticity.
.
But say that a dog certainly suddenly
runs from his car.
You obviously don't have a model for that.
.
So you're going to need to call in work
in memory to solve some of those issues
so you don't hit the dog.
So everything works under prediction
unless the model is very unreliable and
then working memory is called in to solve
some further issues.
An.
Interesting hypothesis I had on the PhD
thesis which I never explored.
I actually don't even think anyone read
this part, but it seems to me to be a
very interesting hypothesis in relation
to free energy in active inference.
So that's why I'm bringing it here in the
Active Inference Institute that as we
know, the brain attempts to minimize free
energy by getting predictions right.
Thus higher need of type two processes
are related to higher free energy
interpreting information in the sense
that when the predictions are working
clearly, then you don't need to have
effort.
But when there are a lot of prediction
error, then you need effort because you
call in the working memory to do a risk
search.
So to minimize a great amount, better
amount of free energy will take more time
and work.
This is more effortful than having
predictions ready that minimize free
energy as quickly as possible.
Before, when probabilities fail, the
system needs to start risking
possibilities.
It searches for other possible solutions
by means of heuristic search.
Heuristic search would be related to more
information and time because it does not
have probable solutions ready.
Instead it needs to investigate its state
space almost from scratch.
We say almost because it is heuristic.
And hence it also will have tricks to get
the correct solution faster.
Unlike group force search, which would
investigate the state space from
beginning to end, we believe reports of
effort would be related to executing more
heuristic searches.
Reports of effort by subjects would seem
to be based on cognitive informational
and physical constraints of reality.
So that's why I think this is an
interesting part of the hypothesis is
because we have this psychological
measure of effort.
But if this is true, then we actually
have a physical measure of effort.
Like if people are working hard on the
problem, that means there's a lot of free
energy going on and they are having to
use this the risk of search to fix some
issues that the model isn't able to fix
by itself.
Yeah, so that's that's the effort part.
So now going for the working memory part,
what's interesting here is that in
working memory, working memory, it's
expected of it that it works like a
classical computer.
So working memory is a widely research
topic in psychology, but in predictive
processing it's rarely, rarely mentioned.
.
And I actually searched the predictive
processing books, control F for working.
And people rarely use this topic because
it's not done by predictive processing.
It has nothing to do with predictive
processing.
It's actually an issue for predictive
processing because well, if you're going
to eliminate classical symbolic
processing altogether, then we need a
predictive processing explanation of
working memory.
And so far I haven't found one and I don'
't think there will be one.
But this also could be just ignorance of
mine.
Maybe there's some paper there which I
haven't found might prove me wrong.
But in any way, working memory is very
aligned with what Turing was thinking
when he was making the connection between
machines and minds.
So if this is a sentence of Alan Turing
explaining his computer, right, the
Turing machine.
And if we change the word computer to
work in memory, it clearly works.
It's almost like it's talking about the
same thing, when of course, if we change
the word here, computer, to predictive
processing, it's clearly not talking
about the same thing.
So the behavior of the computer or
working memory at any moment is
determined by the symbols which it's
observing in his state of mind at that
moment.
We may suppose that there is a bound b to
the number of symbols or squares which
the computer can observe at one moment.
If he wishes to observe more, he must use
successive observations.
We will also suppose that the number of
states of mind which can be taken into
account is finite.
The reason for this are the same
characters as those which restrict the
numbers of symbols.
If we admitted an infinity of states of
mind, some of them would be arbitrarily
close and would be confused.
Again, the restriction is not one which
is seriously affect computation since the
use of more complicated states of mind
can be avoided by writing more symbols on
the tape.
So this is very similar to what we think
about when we're talking about working
memory, not only because we were instance
by Turing, but because of the evidence
that comes from working memory is very
similar to what suspected of this sort of
machine.
Finally, we have speed.
So predictive processing has various
strategies to make the processing be
faster as fast as possible.
While that's not true for symbolic
classical AI, so yeah, Clark says cheap,
fast world exploiting action rather than
the pursuit of truth optimality and
deductive inference is now the key
organizing principle.
When he's talking about predictive
processing, the predictive processor is
always taking certain bets about what the
current state of the world implies losing
accuracy, compensation for speed.
We also have predictive coding in the
more strict sense.
So by predictive coding we mean
specifically the property of the system
to consider from the world only stimulant
which result in greater prediction error.
.
So there's also a filter there which
allows for speed in perception and focus.
.
Beyond predictive prediction relevant
stimulant only permits the agent to
quickly decide forces of action and
select amongst the possible forces.
So predictive processing is tailored to
be fast, necessarily.
Well, that's not the case for symbolic AI
and so that's the explanation for the
difference in speed.
So beyond that, the T two processes need
to figure out the solutions online.
So it's different if you have a prior
prediction that would say to you what the
answer is from having to search its place
from scratch.
Right.
There is also another issue that the
biological brains certainly were not
built for.
A serial heuristic search photo pilotians
say that the morals that the absolute
speed of a process is a property part
excellence of its implementation.
And since the brain does not have a
symbolic processor implemented, if we do
use some sort of heuristic search, it's
like a different adaptation.
It's not what the brain is used to.
Inserting problem spaces is slower than
having a problem outcome ready.
Okay, so that was the work I did in my
PhD thesis.
And those one, those were one of the main
reasons why I think this framework is
good for explaining the differences in
features of dual process theory.
And I actually wrote a prediction that I
recently learned that I wrote this
because I, I forgot I wrote this.
And then I went back to to the thesis and
and I said, well, I actually said this
would happen and it kind of did.
So that was one of the reasons why I
renewed my interest in my PhD thesis.
So what I said was predictive processing
system would be subject to bias from lack
of compositionality such as mistakes in
connectivity, failures in noticing
necessary character, formal rules and so
on.
Precisely the type of mistake, type one
processing incurs.
And so at that point we didn't have large
language models.
In fact, the attention is all unique.
Paper came out in the same year.
And then I noticed that this could be
seen as a prediction of the type of
issues that large language models are
facing, that's reliability.
Hard time keeping the order of units or
steps in complex reasoning or math
straight, hard time letting go of priors.
.
And to my what really motivated me to
start working on this scan was that they
solved this precisely by using dual
process theory and t two agents they're
calling.
So what they're doing now to solve these
reliability issues is adding a heuristic
search to the genetic model and it's
having awesome results.
This is just this year 2023.
So the more they develop these type two
agents to answer these reliability
problems of large language models, the
more the large language models are
getting good at stuff.
So this is a paper, I got the images from
the paper tree of Socks, right, which is
one of the last ones, probably came out
about two months ago, something like that.
.
The way they're doing this implementation
is they're taking the results outputs of
the large language model and they're
doing further reasoning on it and then
feeding the large language model with the
result of the further reasoning.
The further reasoning they're doing is
very similar to the classic symbolic AI.
So here they explain there's a simple
input output prompting here, which is
simply inputting a prompt and the large
language model will give you an output.
And as we know, these outputs sometimes
are very biased.
There's hallucination on it, they're not
reliable, all that stuff.
And last year they figured out that
through chain of thought prompting we
could also already increase the
reliability of these models.
So you give an input and just as we do,
the better prompting when we go to
Chattbc and say, I'll do this better fix
this issue, solve this step by step, some
of the commands that are good for Chatter,
, PT and Chain of thought prompting
automated some of that, some of those
reasoning steps.
And then large language models were
working much better after this.
So this was last year.
And then last year this started a new
trend of research to make these agents
coupled to large language model output
linguistic outputs back into the large
language models to see how they can get
better.
The self consistency one, you give the
input and then there are various
solutions.
The self consistency forces the large
language model to try different solutions
and then you get a majority vote.
So if you have like five similar answers,
some different paths, then this one
SPicked over the one which is less
popular.
And the Tree of Thoughts, which I thought
was most similar to the proposal I had in
psychology, in Duprose theory, is the one
which opens up a problem space.
It's actually pretty much what I just
explained.
In the case of psychology, they open up a
problem space and they start to search
possible solutions which are better than
the original and they feed that back into
the predictive processing, sorry, the
generative model, the large language
model.
And then this one is currently one of the
best ones they have.
So here I made a general diagram of how
this would work.
It's not psychology nor AI.
It's like what's singular in the two?
So we have a generative model here using
probability density functions.
This looks more like a traditional
cognitive cognitive connectionist model
than a predictive processing.
It's just the diagram is not that good.
I'll talk a little about that.
We generate an answer here, which is to
the problem here, and we get a linguistic
output.
And this linguistic output then goes for
an heuristic search using symbolic
representations.
So if you get a better answer here, feeds
it back to the Genitive model and so on.
Basically, the knowledge part is the
Genitive model and the heuristic search
is simply using more steps to see to
prompt it back.
It's more like a prompting scheme than a
new knowledge scheme, which is both true
for the dual process theory model I
created and the heuristic search that's
happening here on the T, two agents for
LLMs.
A better way to do this, and I think Tree
of Thoughts does implementate this, is
that the input layers are trying to
predict the thoughts.
It's a bit more like predictive process
than the other diagram.
And so they're trying to predict the
thoughts and by open up this searching
this problem space during these steps.
We already have new prompts here for the
Gentrific model.
So if you take predictive processing
seriously, and this does happen in the
brain, more likely like this.
I do think that the Tree of Thoughts
paper does say that the intermediary
processes interfere in the searching on
the aliens.
Finally, I thought maybe we could suggest
something from psychology for these
models to keep growing, working
differently based on what we know from
psychology.
So some things that are not implemented
yet is that executive functioning have
these updating abilities in intelligent
forgetting, which is related to insight
problem solving.
It's when you forget something, but it
means, like, you forget the prior,
right?
You're using a different prior, so you're
able to let go of biases.
Right.
There's also work on thinking
dispositions, which could be relevant.
Sentences like this belief should always
be revised in response to new information
of our evidence.
So these would be, like, imperative
linguistic knowledge, which would have to
be added on.
I don't know where, but likely would help
work.
There's a lot of thinking dispositions
that are relevant to our successful
reasoning.
And this is just one example.
The literature knows a lot more examples
that could be relevant.
We have in creativity research, we have
this generative phase, which is similar
to what the generative models are doing,
but we do not have the exploratory
processes going on, which is common in
the creativity research literature.
But it's what we do with, for instance,
mid journey when we're doing better
prompts.
So maybe using these exploratory
processes from the creativity research,
we can also automate the exploratory part
of the creativity processes that these
image generators are getting to, and not
just the generative part.
And finally, I think the embodiment, you
don't have robots or anything like that
that do this sort of reasoning.
So AI on the computer and also stuff from
active entrance, which was not considered
slightly related to embodiments in the
sense of navigating the world and
predicting the world.
That stuff is far from happening in the
traditional Galileans we have.
So, yeah, that's a lot of stuff.
Sand, maybe I hope you guys have some
comments.
As I said, I haven't been able to talk
about this to anyone, and I do think I
have some, at least some maybe some
relevant stuff that I've published.
But since I'm not famous and I don't have
people to talk to, it's mostly gone
unnoticed.
So thanks for being stay tuned.
Daniel: Thank you.
Awesome presentation.
All right!
Nick, it'd be awesome to hear your introduction
and then take it wherever you'd like to
go.
Nick Byrd: Sure.
So first, thanks, Samuel, for interesting
talk.
And I've been really pleased to find your
research.
I guess maybe I'm supposed to say
something about who I am, where I am.
So I'm Nick Bird.
I'm at the Stevens Institute of
Technology in the New York City
metropolitan area in a department that's
kind of interdisciplinary.
So we have, like, philosophy and
quantitative social science, but also,
like, people doing, like, music and
visual arts and all sorts of other things.
.
I tend to do more of the philosophy and
quantitative social science stuff.
So I'm kind of also interested in human
reasoning.
And so much of the people I'm reading and
citing and drawing on in my research are
a lot of the people that you saw in the
opening slides that we saw people like
was on and Conneman Tversky and Mercier
and Sperber and a lot of the other people
that were cited.
I think Samuel does a really good job to
incorporate the kind of like shoulders of
giants that we're standing on in terms of
the philosophy of mind, right.
The voters and the Pilitians and these
people.
And one thing that I think is on
everybody's mind these days is these
large language models.
So I'm really glad to see how this dual
process theory that emerged from research
like economan and diversky's on these
problems like the conjunction fallacy
problems or the waste on selection guard
task or the conjunction fallacy tasks,
how that has been applied to models like
large language models and what we can
learn from that.
And then I think the coolest thing about
the preprint print is how we could kind
of port back and forth the learnings from
both the computer science and the
cognitive science to improve one another,
right?
So I think that one of the neat things
about this preprint that Samuel was
giving us at the end is that we're kind
of taking what we think is a model of
reflective reasoning that we represent
certain parts of a problem and maybe
reason more carefully and effortfully
about them in certain situations in ways
that might help us.
And how can we help these large language
models do the same?
Because it does seem like large language
models function, at least the ones that
we interact with online.
Mostly.
They seem to function mostly as like a
system one or type one process.
They're just kind of like quickly
generating lots of text or imagery or
something like that.
But they're not necessarily reflecting on
it in the ways that we would think that a
human is capable of and they might not
even be capable of representing things in
the same way that we do.
Yeah, so I thought that was a really
interesting idea.
Using chain of thought and tree of
thought models to kind of create a
reflective level or reflective system
within the models seems just like a
really valuable idea and just a really
great synthesis of research in multiple
disciplines, something that I think few
people are actually very good at.
It's like incorporating some of the best
insights from multiple fields.
We're often pretty siloed in academia.
So I just think this is great work and I
hope more people will appreciate and pay
attention to it and build on it.
So one of the things that stood out to me
in this presentation more so than when I
was, like, reading this 2023 preprint
analytic Reasoning for Large language
models by Dr.
Bellini Leiche.
The thing that stood out to me is this
idea that Bellini Leiche and Frankish
sort of switched which of these two types
of reasonings processes are supposed to
be context dependent or context sensitive
or however you would want to word that.
And I started thinking, well, I wonder if
there's a sense in which both types of
responses or both types of reasoning are
somewhat context dependent and I'll just
say what I mean.
And then maybe, Samuel, you can kind of
say what you think I should think or
clarify the view of the predictive and
reflective framework or something.
So the thought I was having was, well, in
a familiar context, these intuitive
predictions, these type one processes,
our gut response, so to speak, those are
going to be pretty useful because they're
well trained.
We have a lot of experience that we're
drawing on.
So like our gut response, our first
response is often quite good.
It's in these less familiar contexts, or
maybe similarly familiar, but, like, way
higher stakes or something.
But it's in these other contexts where we
might think, maybe I should slow down and
make sure I've double checked whatever my
initial impulse is before I just accept
it because there's a lot riding on this.
Or, like, I'm just not used to this type
of problem, so I need to slow down.
And so there's a sense in which what
context is doing is not just showing up
in one or the other type of reasoning,
but it's sort of like determining which
type of reasoning might be best at the
moment.
But I'm wondering, is that just totally
compatible with what you're imagining or
is that somehow a deviation from the
framework, the predictive and reflective
framework?
Samuel: Yeah, thanks for the thoughts.
There compliments and thanks for the
question as well.
So the reason why I think context needs
always some sort of type one help is
because of the constraints we have
learned from symbolic AI.
So if I'm saying that type two reasoning
have the same constraints, then it cannot
be contextual because it doesn't work
like that.
We know that if it fails in context, it
fails bad.
But of course we do need to like when we
have a novel situation, we often solve
this by context, right?
So how could this be?
And I think it's by the interconnection
of the power of the two system.
So we always start with a prediction,
which in this case would be mistaken, and
then we have to search for novel answers.
.
And in this search we make the contextual
comparisons.
So it can't be that the system too is
making the comparison on its own.
I think it's more likely that when it's a
case of context that stems from a novel
situation and then the two systems have
to figure out it together.
Likely in the sense that I was pointing
out here in the end, these predictions
that go over the thoughts, they most
likely are the ones that will solve these
context issues in novel problems, I'd
argue something like that.
Nick Byrd: Okay, I think that's somewhat
helpful.
So then maybe what I'm thinking is
something along what the lines you were
saying at the end.
You were saying how there's still kind of
an opportunity to understand things like
executive function in this framework.
And I think that's maybe part of what I'm
wondering about.
So I guess I'm wondering if there's more
to be said within this predictive and
reflecting framework about how each of
these two types of processes get selected
or, like, what might help the system.
Samuel: Hold on.
Nick Byrd: Go ahead.
Samuel: That specific point you just
remember, I just remembered something
that's related.
So, yeah, clearly our working memory or
type two reasoning likely does more than
that.
It does this, but likely more than that.
There's likely also a belief bank,
something like the thinking dispositions,
some sort of knowledge bank, which is
related to type two processing.
So Keith Franklin does this distinction
between flat out beliefs and I'm not
remembering terms, but he has a type one
belief and type two belief.
Type one belief is that belief you have,
but you're not fully confident of it.
And the type two belief is the belief you
have when you have a very firm political
position and you state it with obvious
words that you sure you believe that.
So there's likely to be some sort of
different belief structure as well, which
I don't talk about at all thesis of the
work.
So I'm not saying, obviously that this is
a complete model of reasoning, and
obviously we'll need more to figure out
how reasoning works.
Nick Byrd: Yeah, okay.
That's also helpful.
I'm wondering if Daniel, did you want to
weigh in?
Daniel: Well, I think it's a very
interesting question about which of those
modes are engaged or how they're balanced
through time.
And how does this connect to what's known
as the context window in today's
transformer type large language models.
So how do you map the computational
attributes of large language models today,
, like architecturally or their Ram or
CPU usage?
How do you map that onto, for example,
human cognitive processes?
Do you think that's useful or there are
any insights there?
Samuel: Well, I'm mostly making a
relation between predictive processing
and generative models, but I know that
large language models are not entirely
the same as what active inference is
saying.
I'm aware of that, but there is some
similarity specifically in regards to the
generative model part.
So I'm not sure I'm not an AI specialist
to be sure which details of a generative
model could be true of the human brain.
And I'm most likely betting that the
people who study generative models in the
brain, like the Frisons and all, have
figured out something like what our
generative models do.
Daniel: One other thought or nick, you
want to add there just thought of some
different ways whether people have
connected it explicitly to the literature
on working memory in predictive
processing.
I think, as you pointed out, it's
definitely a link that is not highlighted.
.
It's one that we recently heard from
Professors Walker and Monriquez and
Pristine in the recent Livestream 53 that
was on like, cognitive paleoanthropology
looking at human working memory.
But some ways that people have
incorporated working memory is like a
nested model that carries context at a
deeper time, but that is not necessarily
like an actual mechanism that gives rise
to why type one and type two are the way
they are.
So I thought that was a very provocative
direction to go to move past the
descriptive and then to look at the
underlying generative model of why these
outcomes are the way they are.
Even though these cognitive phenomena are
causes of other things happening, they
are also caused by some influenceable or
contextual or variable aspects.
And when we lose that context dependence
of the cognitive systems, then they're
totally lifted and disembodied don't
really help.
So by putting the primacy on that
predictive processing element, I think it
opens the door to connecting those areas
beyond just mentioning the terms in
proximity, but to really support
different epistemologies from predictive
processing as a model or approach.
Samuel: Yeah.
Can you go on that idea again?
I'm not sure what you want me to comment.
.
Can you summarize that again and make it
a question?
Daniel: Sure.
What do you think the epistemological
consequences are of taking predictive
processing the way that you have
approached it here versus alternative or
prior approaches to cognitive sciences?
Samuel: Okay, but what do you mean by
epistemological.
Daniel: Normative?
Samuel: How we know.
Daniel: How it influences our
understanding of how we know or seek or
practice or do or decide.
Samuel: Perfect.
Okay, let me think about that, for
instance.
Yeah, I think one of the best what this
helps with most is explaining dual
process theory because dual process
theory is in bad shape in terms of
concepts, in terms of theory and
formulation.
People have no idea what these systems
refer to in the mind brain.
They often have different intuitions into
this.
And basically what I most think this work
is relevant for is for saving dual
process theory from criticism, which has
been happening in psychology.
So people are like, it seems like we're
talking about the left and right brain,
something like that, something that we
don't know for sure what these two
systems are.
Right.
So this is a good way forward, I think,
for dual process theory.
And as I said, dual process theory does
have some value in itself.
So, yeah, saving the process theory, I
think is a good direction for this model.
.
But also if we think about the advantages
of it would be something like, for
instance, it could have helped us had the
idea of using Chain of Thoughts or Tree
of thoughts.
Had anyone read this before.
So it can help us make these sorts of
predictions that we shouldn't have some
sort of zero reasoning coupled to the
gentle models.
So yeah, I think it could help us think
further on on AI, if we AI, like Nick was
saying, to incorporating more stuff in
psychology that we know that's certainly
missing here, but here we have a
direction of what we should incorporate
and so on.
But I'm also unaware of the working
memory research from predictive
processing you mentioned.
And if you want to go back to that and
explain me some more of that, I'd be
happy to hear.
Daniel: Yeah, sure.
So not that this is the most effective
way to implement a memory system, but at
least that this provides analytical
method for measuring or describing them.
If one were going to have the five digit
number, you could imagine a nested model
where the lowest level is the ones place
and it's nested within a decision tree of
tens places and hundreds and so on.
And then there's some seek or access
policy or strategy that helps speak the
number in reverse.
And some cognitive or computational
limitation is just how well that
cognitive agent can perform on that test.
.
Again, that doesn't mean that's the
mechanism that's being used, but that
would be a way to use a nested generative
model to encode like multiple levels of
spatial or temporal variability.
But context becomes an issue because you'
're basically just expanding the
possibility space looking for sparser and
sparser associations.
So if you don't have a good
compositionality or really well definable
well articulated causal process, then you'
're just building these all by all models
that you're going to be searching through
in the dark.
Samuel: Yeah, one point I want to comment
on that is that, well, it's not clear
that the best way to reason will be the
way humans reason.
Right?
So we might eventually have a different
way of implementing working memory on an
LLM which would be more effective than
ours.
There's also to the other side, there's
also the point that it seems that the
limited capacity we have on working
memory, maybe it's not just a lack of
power, maybe it's necessary.
So we kind of like don't lose our minds
in the sense that we have a limited space
to search and then we're able to search
this limited space.
And if it was too, if we have too much
space to search because we have super
working memory, then we wouldn't be able
to finish the task anytime.
So maybe this is like a physical good
barrier, something that helps.
And it's interesting that what I find
interesting is that okay, the AI may find
a lot of different and better ways to
implement work memory, but it's
interesting that they implemented a
worksheet memory or a search agent, which
was very like the way I described in the
thesis.
That was what I found amazing.
As you were saying.
There's very ways to implement it working
memory, but they did it in a very similar
way in the sense of searching the space
after the genitive model has offered a
solution.
So I don't know, maybe that's a good
indication that this is on the right
track, but it also may just simply be a
simple way they found to solve the
problem.
And it was just by coincidence similar to
this.
Yeah, maybe the correct way or the way
the brain does may also be different.
We don't know.
All we have was the limited evidence I
offered a bit more obviously and some
constraints we know on AI information
processing.
We have to figure it out.
And I think that this implementation
stuff you're asking is mostly due to the
AI people to find out or the math people,
the systems to figure out.
Daniel: Nick, do you want to comment or a
question or I'll ask one from the chat.
Samuel: Yeah.
Nick Byrd: So I just have a kind of a
bigger picture question that kind of gets
us into the realm of these chat bots,
right?
So you in this preprint and in this talk
have like given us a variety of different
tasks in the heuristics and biases
literature.
The the conjunction fallacy task, the the
lend a problem, some people call it, or
these cognitive reflection test questions.
.
And you know, there's a, there's like a
paper in the fall that showed that a
preprint in the fall that last fall that
showed 2022, that showed GPT-3 and 3.5.
And even the earlier versions, like,
showed a lot of the human, like, faulty
intuitions.
Like it basically fell for the lure
pretty often.
Sometimes, like most of the time it was
falling for the lure.
But then as soon as GPT Four was
available to be studied and used on these
models, it was like performing basically
near perfect.
And when it did get the incorrect
response, it wasn't necessarily the lure,
it was just like some other general type
of error it was making, like
misinterpreting the question altogether
or something.
And it seems like the predicting,
predictive and reflecting model framework
could have at least two different ways of
explaining this.
One is what happened is they changed the
AI's like type one thinking or whatever
so that it could respond intuitively to
all these, but intuitively and correctly,
so it didn't need to reflect.
Or it could be that they somehow created
this reflective type system with either
like a chain of thought or a tree of
thought or some other type of system that
helps it actually engage in reflection on
these tasks or whatever the analog of
reflection would be for a chat bot.
And so I'm wondering if you have thoughts
on this, as you've been thinking about
this or talking to anyone about this, how
do you think they did this?
Obviously we have to speculate because a
lot of the data is proprietary.
But I'm just curious to get your
thoughts?
Samuel: Yeah, that's an awesome question.
.
I actually forgot to mention this on the
presentation that the biases they make on
the recent test last year were exactly
the ones the humans made.
So if we fed it some dual process real,
it would give exactly our mistakes.
That's so amazing.
I'm not certain why that happened, but it
did and how they fixed this.
So, yeah, I do think that they trained
the model on these tasks because people
were able to get similar issues by
changing the questions a little bit.
So I think they cheated on that in the
sense that they trained on known problems,
, but that's not true of new problems.
If you give it some different formulation
and feed it to 3.5 new version, it's
still failing.
But the people on Open AI, they are aware
of this chain of thought research, they
are aware of this tree of thought
research, but I don't think they want to
depend or rely on these external agents.
So they recently released a report where
they are trying to reinforce intermediate
steps of reasoning on GPC four.
So they try to simulate internally what
the chain of thoughts reasoning is doing
externally by reinforcing the
intermediate steps of reasoning so that
it starts failing composition, helping.
So on.
Daniel: A lot of thought on that.
I was reminded by Daniel Dennett's
framework or model in Darwin's dangerous
idea of cranes and skyhooks.
And so some building is built and then
the question is like, was it built with
cranes or with top down hung skyhooks
that just sort of descend from nowhere,
hold everything up while it's all being
built?
And it's like, well, no, it's with cranes.
.
And then if you need a big crane, you can
use a smaller crane to assemble a crane.
So that's kind of a bottom up
constructive metaphor, whereas the sky
hook is like the top down
compositionality.
And that's when you get to certain level
of sophistication for a cognitive system,
it can make the blueprint or the plan
like maybe what we would associate with
the expected free energy calculation, not
just the variational free energy
calculation.
So at some point when a plan can be made,
it requires a strategy between type one
and type two switching and probably other
switches too.
And so that crane approach, you need a
lot of compute to do a bottom up.
So even though it's kind of weird to
think about, it's almost like the current
large models are very bottom up because
they're very bottom up from syntax and
they don't have what you refer to as
imperative linguistic knowledge, which
can be normative as well as a heuristic
for knowledge.
And that's potentially a small model, but
it contains wisdom that's explicit and
practices and stances or dispositions as
you described.
And so it's kind of like it's not a
denial of embodiment to also clarify what
this skyhook ability is.
And that's type two like so I think.
I guess.
What do you think about that?
Or how do you connect this to anything in
that area?
Samuel: Yeah, I'm going to make you do
the summary and the question again,
because although I did track some of what
you mean, I'm not sure which ones made to
comment on that.
Daniel: Do you think that the landscape
of large and small models would be
different if people took on board some of
the features you described, like
imperative linguistic knowledge,
seriously into construction of models?
Samuel: So let me just see if this is
something you're asking.
So they're doing small models now for
phones and open source models for phones,
and they have the issue of not being able
to scale up.
Right?
Because if you scale up too much, then
you can't run on the phone.
So you're asking if we can implement
something like Tree of Thoughts to help
these smaller models.
Is that what you said?
Daniel: Yes.
Samuel: Are you sure or are you just
saying, okay, go for that?
Daniel: That's an example of what it
would mean to re understand.
Like where do we need an API call to a
cloud center?
Or where could some context be locally
computed with much more of a type One?
What are some type two problems that we
might be able to type one our way out
of?
What are some type one areas where things
are not working and a type two
description might be advantageous?
Samuel: Yeah, I think they're getting
onto that.
And they're being able to make these
smaller, smaller models precisely because
of these sorts of discoveries they made
on Chain of Thoughts.
Right.
There's also stuff about being able to
train on specific data.
I read one.
It's called?
Textbooks are all you need.
They're training smaller, smaller models
on textbooks, and they're doing better.
So, yeah, there are differences in
training smaller models, different data,
but there's also the possibility of
making them more reliable based on what I'
'm calling T Two Agents or Train of
Thoughts, stuff like that.
And again, we don't know if that's all we
can do externally, but I would argue that
we would need necessarily some sort of
external mechanism coupled to any large
language model for the best results
because of the differences in
representations, mainly because of this.
Unless the large language model somehow
makes a symbolic representation emerge
from its processes, it's not clear that
it has done so.
But unless it does so, and it uses that
reliably because it may even have
generated some sort of symbolic process
internally, but doesn't always use that
or doesn't know when to use that, most
likely we're going to need something
external to the language model, and this
is some clues to how to implement that.
And also, I think, in our brain, it's
kind of external not only in the sense of
our minds, but also in the brain, since
it's a recent step in evolution, we don't
see I don't know lizards reasoning in
type two manner.
Right.
We do see Chintenzees reasoning in type
two manner, but not as much as we do.
So it's very human like reasoning.
It's just that going back to the context
problem, animals do solve contextual
problems.
That's why they can live.
Right.
So the issue is not actually the context
there.
It's more like some boost on reasoning
capacity.
And that boost on reasoning capacity may
be related to the prefrontal cortex, as
we know.
And so, of course, the prefrontal cortex
is also a network.
It's not a serial Turing machine.
But if there's somewhere that's
implementing a serial machine or a
symbolic classic AI machine or symbolic
reasoning or something like that, most
likely it would be the prefrontal cortex,
which is kind of like a distinct
addiction addition to the brain and maybe
something related to language, which is
also distinct, a new addition to the
brain.
Also, I'm very convinced by the photo and
deletion argument in 88 that you're going
to need symbolic processing anyway.
Either the model is going to generate
that symbolic processing, or you're going
to have to feed it for him, or else you'
're going to have hallucination of
mistakes and reasoning because of the
nature of because of the nature of
distributed representations.
Right.
It's uncertain and ambiguous by nature.
That's why I'm not entirely convinced
that only probabilistic representations
will be enough to solve hallucination
issues.
Daniel: Awesome.
Nick, do you have any other questions or
areas you want to mention or ask?
Nick Byrd: I think those were my main
questions.
I don't know if there's anything in the
Chat that you wanted to touch on before
we go.
I know we're maybe over time, I'll.
Daniel: Go with one from the Chat, and
then we can have any closing thoughts.
So Glia maximalist asks, are you familiar
with visual pathways in the human brain?
Specifically the dorsal where and
ventral?
What pathways do you think this maps onto
the two systems you describe for problem
solving?
Samuel: Okay, yeah.
So like I said, in 2008, evans tried to
accomplish that unifying vision of due
process theory, but I'm not very
convinced by that.
He also said, well, we can't do this as
of yet, but I do think it's possible, as
I said on the presentation, I just don't
know how to do it, how to have a
convincing theory of everything, of dual
process theory in the brain.
It does go on to other regions.
Like, you have automatic motor responses
and controlled motor responses.
Like you said, there's different pathways
in reasoning, in figuring out stuff in
the visual field.
Maybe the what would be related to
something and where to another most
likely the what would be tapping on to
type two processing.
I'm not sure how the where would be
tapping on that, but yeah, as I'm trying
to make the point, if we extend it to the
whole brain, we lose what we've learned.
We're not sure how that applies.
Daniel: Cool.
Well, Nick, any penultimate last words?
Samuel: You muted.
Oh, wait.
Daniel: Unmute and then continue.
Nick Byrd: Sorry about that.
No worries.
Thanks to both of you, Dr.
Bellini, Lighte and Daniel, for
coordinating this.
And I'm really just glad to have found
the research and to discuss it and
connect and looking forward to further
conversations, to be honest.
Daniel: Awesome.
Sam, any closing thoughts?
Samuel: Yeah, I'm just sad I couldn't go
much beyond what I said on the
presentation.
Most of the stuff you guys asked, I'm not
sure I have good answers for that.
Basically, what I've done is all I know,
and I'm not sure how to go on the future
with this, and maybe someone in the
audience will do.
So I hope that helps, guys.
Great.
Daniel: I hope so, too.
All right, till next time.
Thank you.
Nick Byrd: Bye.